good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how success
is the hangover of failure over the
Newmark echo I think the best advice
that I could give you on success is to
know that success is merely the hangover
or failure and that failure is an
essential ingredient in creating a
learning atmosphere for you so that you
can accrue those learnings the small
incremental steps of failure and collect
enough learning so that you can arrive
at success right I think we're taught in
the system that failure is something
that you should be ashamed of failure is
for the dumb kids because you can S you
get a D right you're not competent you
didn't comply you didn't create the
evidence of your worthiness but I can
tell you is someone who's successful
right both financially and from a wealth
creation point of view but more
importantly a wealth that matters that
success doesn't look like an a-plus it
doesn't look like a hundred and ten and
extra credit and failure isn't as simple
as an F it's not always always a failure
could be very gray right and being able
to discern what you might arrive at an
event or in your life where you think
that wow I've succeeded and you're
getting the a perfect affirmation from
all these outside forces but if it's not
aligned authentically with to whom which
you are it could very much feel like
failure failure is only real failure if
you don't learn anything from it we're
so caught up on failure as being this
really bad negative thing and what
happens is people take one shot and if
they don't hit then they quit
in what world do you take one shot and
make it it's very rare
it takes a shot after another shot after
another shot in business in life in
athletics and music it's anything that
you want to do you will suck at the
beginning you will fail over and over
and over and over again and because
people don't hit it on the first try
they'll convince that it's never going
to work out for them and quite often
then they become the little man to other
people into because I didn't achieve my
goal now you can't go out and achieve
yours either it's never going to work
and they become the super negative
person just brings everybody down most
people are so afraid to fail that they
don't even try and that's the biggest
failure of all understand that it only
takes one thing to hit for you to become
a massive success if you look at actors
a lot of people had a tiny role after a
tiny role out their tiny role and they
look back on their roles now and they
cringe at their acting abilities but
that's how they got started and none of
those were hits and eventually they had
their big breakthrough you look at
entrepreneurs it's the same thing a lot
of entrepreneurs start with a little
business and a little business and
another one that doesn't go well it goes
under little business and then they come
up with that idea that really takes off
they make their first successful company
if you look at my youtube channel as an
example I've done so many videos four
thousand videos on the channel and it
took a long time before any of them hit
if you look at the top ten series as an
example I tried that as one idea and
that was one out of tons of ideas and
that idea hit and then that became from
once a week to twice the week to five
times a week and thanks to your feedback
we're able to collect you know 3,000
plus votes on different people to
profile because I never thought that
we'd have enough people the profile 52
in a year I thought that was max would
double that 100 in a year let alone five
times a week I didn't think we have
enough content you guys provided it to
me we have cut more series on this
channel than most people create I'm okay
with cutting I get an idea the first
thing I want to do and here's a process
the first thing I do when I get an idea
is I want to try it test it don't make
it some big crazy
thing that becomes impossible to ever do
you get an idea find a low cost low
super easy way to get started on trying
it and see do you like it does it make
you come alive you want to go do it
again it was there any kind of reaction
to it how can you make it better and
tweak it or I was not enjoyable I don't
like doing that I don't want to do it
anymore people didn't like it either so
we're going to cut success will come
again when you combine the thing that
you love doing with what the market
wants the thing that you absolutely have
a passion for with what people want you
have to have both if it's just what you
want then this is the hobby that you do
for yourself
it was just what the market wants
consumers want then you're never going
to be the best because you're only doing
it for money and you'll have a passion
to really be great at that business has
to be the combination what you love
doing with what people want and if you
love doing it have it figured out what
people want yet they keep hustlin
hustlin hustlin so you can provide value
to those people so you can build a great
business but the next time you get this
great idea of something that you want to
do stop just making a list of different
ideas that just we could add into our
list of to do the list of ideas that one
day we want to do something about get
over the fear of failure
start small take that idea and find a
way today to move forward on it and see
does it make you come alive so you want
to keep doing it again and again and
again and if not throw it away move on
to the next one
failures only feedback failure is only
showing you a way of how not to do
something and to have a deep passion for
learning how to do it
don't quit on your dreams because you're
afraid of family so the question today
today is I'm curious what is one of the
biggest lessons that you've learned from
failure in the past leave it down in the
comments below really curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Michelle Brittany from Michelle
Britton calm Michelle thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really means a lot to
me and I hope you're enjoying reading it
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you seem to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I will see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot event
I like spread-eagle
[Music]
eventually joined Harper's Bazaar us and
in 1976 it was you were fired and I find
that extraordinary you know they they
were very clear and that they thought
that I would never understand the
American market I remember I was the
editor on one shoot that was I think it
was a French fashion shows and I just
decided that it would be interesting to
have dreadlocks on the models and I
think that that pushed them further than
they could they could bear so that was
that was that was it for me but I you
know I think it's always part of life to
have some knocks as well as some
successes and take risks and you know to
learn so I think it's healthy for
everyone to to lose a job as well as to
gain a job you wake up in the morning
you're failing so you blame the
president you blame Congress you blame
grease blame the euro I mean your
construction in the street it's a mayor
oh it's didn't and you wake up in the
morning and you look in the mirror and
you're not failing because it's the
other guy's fault where's the economy's
fault
but if you looked in a mirror and said
I'm failing because of me you wouldn't
like it and you change that and I
believe the common denominator of
failure in any business is excuses as
long as you wake up and blame poor sales
on the economy or an environment then
you have no motivation to make it better
because it's not your fault but in the
worst economic environment for five
years in this country the ago.the in
this country that we've seen in our
lifetimes do people making a lot of
money weren't there
in the height of that recession or
people selling advertising people
opening restaurants people building
businesses somebody is making money so
the excuse is bull it's bull so wake up
in the morning and own your failure look
in the mirror and say I'm failing
because of me and you won't like it
and then you'll change it but as long as
you don't put it on you you have no
motivation to change it so in short if
you own your failure you'll own your
success if you don't own your failure
you'll never dig out
and I find that in any business always
the common denominator of failure
personally is excuses you don't want to
be a failure dear you don't want to look
in the mirror and experience that if you
can't blame anybody but yourself you're
going to change you're going to fight it
out that's the deal
failure is part of life I mean the
difference for me though is I'm a
failure as a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm going to
fail but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability to influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that messed me up
but I show people that didn't let it
stop me and you only to stop you and I
think I think that's really a secret
matter and if everything you touch was
successful where I got to relate to
people's know you'll be right and also
be total bull and everyone know it's
both and also you'd be bored silly I
mean think about it if you just said I
want this to happen I want this to
happen you know people don't value it
they don't fight for you know it's like
you see kids sometimes in it you know
your parents will say you're not going
to value this if you don't work for it
and you're keeping on oh well you just
give it to me but it's true you know the
things we've worked the hardest for we
value the most so I think you know the
purpose of the goal is not getting it
anyway the purpose of goal you know is
what who you become when you become is
going to make you happier kind of make
you sad so I'm not looking for an
effortless approach there's no such
thing